hey please stop right there hey stop  officer merlier announced police twice  he wore a standard Patrol uniform and  walked from a marked Patrol vehicle with  emergency lights activated  officer Miller ordered Smith to stop  three times all while pointing his duty  weapon at him and Smith appears to look  directly at him  put your hands up  put your hands up dude  the officer told Smith twice to put his  hands up  Smith ignored the commands the gun  pointed at him and walked toward five  uninvolved citizens at the park  the officer just yelled stop reaching  but Smith reached into his shorts and  pulled out a gun  thank you  Smith is now holding his stolen gun a  loaded nine millimeter Ruger pistol